rck ont fini ou pas c'est la question du
face à face de ce soir nos invités
nos invités rx trautmann mer les
républicains de colmar en alsace et
florian philippot président des patries
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions en discussion rt france
x30 malheur on vient de le voir un
mathieu klein et ados
robinet appel à confiner oui pardon
arnaud robinet a lui aussi un élu les
républicains comme vous bonne ou
mauvaise idée
bonjour je considère que la date du 27
et du 28 me paraît une échéance trop
proche il faut laisser le temps au aux
gens de pouvoir rentrer chez eux jouent
en alsace il ya quand même pas mal de
touristes qui sont présents chez nous et
qui sont là certainement jusqu'au 30
siens voir le 1er janvier
donc le créer un conte finança les
obligera à rentrer aux oies
éventuellement être bloqués sur place
ensuite je ne suis pas favorable à un
recompte finement l'échelle du grand est
passé le grand de contest est une très
grande région la situation est très très
très différentes d'un département à
l'autre
alors s'il ya des confinement à réaliser
regardons cela l'échelle des
départements en fonction des chiffres
réels de la pandémie n'est pas le grand
test qui est soit particulièrement tous
été touchés joua également la franche
comté à certains de départements qui
sont bien plus touchées par contre on
sent bien que cette augmentation
obligera le gouvernement à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions dont
éventuellement re confignon dont les
modalités restent à définir
je constate aussi par exemple dans mon
hôpital de colmar où j'ai su président
du conseil de surveillance
nos services de médecine générale sont
davantage touchés évidemment et une
progression très important d admission
médecine générale mais en même temps je
constate que les services de réanimation
aujourd'hui ne sont pas tendues tout
simplement parce que les médecins ont
acquis une certaine expérience
on n'est plus obligé d'arriver pour
ventiler les les malades et il ya des
protocoles ça dit à des protocoles
médicaux qui font que les décompression
physique sont moins rapides par rapport
à ce qu'on a constaté de au mois de mars
donc regardons la situation département
par département
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas trop se
précipiter
florian philippot votre réaction à ce
qui se dit par rapport
au maire de nancy ou encore de reims
votre élection vous qui avait déjà
évoqué à plusieurs reprises le terme de
dictature sanitaire quand on parle de
confinement notamment même c'est à dire
qu'il faudrait quand même un moment
réalisé que le confinement c'est pas
salé par un je veux dire on ne joue pas
ou gens comme eux enfin on joue aux lego
ou playmobil à laisser comme cela les
gens chez eux à fermer des métiers des
commerces
parce que derrière tout cela il ya des
drames je veux dire il ya des drames il
ya des drames économiques et sociaux
évidence dans les drames sur l'éducation
il ya des drames de la solitude de la
dépression et puis il ya les rames
salutaire parce qu'il ya des maladies
qui ne sont plus traités correctement
on le sait tant à voir d'ailleurs de
réelles certitudes le sait moins qu'on
puisse dire sur l'efficacité même de ces
confinement contre le coréen virus le
jeu dire au gouvernement on a un taux de
positivité vous venez de le rappeler en
france extrêmement bas le plus bas
depuis l'été 4 4% 4,4 douze mille cas
hier quinze mille cas aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya énormément de test parce
que des gens qui vont se tester avant
noël on va jamais fait autant de tests
mais le ski concept pourcentage il au
plus bas depuis le mois d'août
bon donc y'a rien qui justifie tout ça
et de toute façon que celui ci fit
d'autant moins que on va pas continuer
ad vitam aeternam affaires du
confinement déconfinement re confinement
etc
c'est sans fin c'est pas perdre donc on
ferait mieux de travailler si vous
voulez comme les pays qui réussissent
dans le monde notamment l'extrême orient
taïwan singapour corée du sud au japon
sur le traitement sur la prévention
on sait qu'elle est chose maintenant qui
fonctionne ou alors on ne veut pas le
savoir parce que trop de conflits
d'intérêts pour qu'on puisse nous le
dira mais qu'on arrête de saccager des
métiers nos libertés accessoirement de
liberté individuelle nos libertés
publiques le moral général de la
population avec des solutions qui relève
de la seule aux sciences et non pas de
la science éclairés tels qu'on aimerait
la voir
vous savez au japon il ya pas d âge à
lui tout finement ce même interdit par
la constitution japonaise
ils ont fait autrement ils ont même
jamais fermer leur commerce lord
restaurant et par contre ils ont traité
les gens voient là et ils ont un système
moderne dans ce pays où il ya des
machines uv qui dès qu'on allume les
trains des rames de métro etc
ça c'est un pays moderne nous c'est
moyen âge non franchement
c'est les celliers du moyen-âge eric
straumann pour certains le gouvernement
n'est pas allé assez loin dans les
mesures de restriction
quand on voit par exemple l'italie
l'angleterre du sud ou encore l'ontario
qui re copine qui le confine à ce qu'un
côté d'eux
de courage dans la politique vous savez
je connecte japon je connais taiwan
l'état d'esprit des gens n'est pas le
même chez nous 1
on a une vieille tradition de port du
masque par exemple à taïwan et au japon
depuis des décennies d'ailleurs on se
moquait toujours un petit peu des
japonais qui était paris à paris avec
avec leurs masques on voit bien qu'ils
ont pris des mesures sanitaires qui
d'abord ont été prises rapidement et
ensuite qu'ils sont aussi appliqués pour
jouer le préfet du haut rhin qui a
décidé à juste titre d'imposer le port
du masque dans tout dans tout l'est dans
les centres ville et à proximité des
commerces
la mesure est très très mal respectée si
ça fonctionne à taiwan et si ça
fonctionne au japon c'est parce que les
japonais sont quand même très
disciplinés aller voir un mode de
transport collectif au japon on respecte
les règles de distanciation sociale et
on porte le masque ce qui est
malheureusement loin d'être le cas en
france et je regrette comme mon collègue
est évidemment qu'on soit obligé de
confiner mais ça tient aussi parfois à
l'absence des disciplines de nous
compris tes compatriotes
il s'agit pas seulement des français les
italiens sont certainement avec le même
état d'esprit et le même état d'esprit
en allemagne mais on peut pas comparer
la situation
l'angleterre du sud a également qui rend
confine avec cette nouvelle souche du
corps n'avait réussi à l'ontario
également qui est avare confiné dès
samedi avec une annonce qui a eu lieu
hier ou avant-hier en fait c'est une
question de cycle moi j'avais fait un
petit peu ce que 17 novembre
j'avais dit début décembre honda des
confiné je ressentais bien la stratégie
du gouvernement va des confiné avant les
fêtes
bonjour et même penser qu'on puisse
éventuellement ouvrir les restaurants
pour donner un peu d'oxygène dans ce
secteur d'activité on allait re confiné
mois de janvier là où l'impact
économique sera moins fort c'est un soin
choix qui a été planifié par le
gouvernement français malheureusement la
fin malheureusement en tout cas ils ne
donnent pas très clairement la leur
position aujourd'hui mais je suis
quasiment sûr qu'on va rentrer dans un
poids dans une procédure de reconfirmer
en janvier puisque ça a été planifié
ainsi et que
la pandémie est bien ce une courbe avec
eu des hauts et des bas et dès que ça
remonte on va rentrer dans ce processus
de confinement c'est aujourd'hui
malheureusement là la seule solution
pour gérer les éventuelles difficultés
dans nos services de réanimation mais je
suis moins sûr que ce soit aussi utile
qu'au mois de mars au mois de mars des
services de réal était totalement saturé
ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
donc regardons un petit peu comment ça
fonctionne dans ses services de
rénovation
regardons aussi comment la médecine
progresse parce que c'est assez
remarquable ce qui ce fait ces dernières
semaines où les gens enfin plus
fréquemment la maison et on n'est plus
obligé d'un tube et tout le monde voilà
puis regardons c'est vrai un petit peu
ce qui se passe en asie du sud est en
particulier taiwan japon mais là ce
moment là il faut une grande discipline
il ya une ville en allemagne où le maire
avait imposé le port du masque très tôt
aux moines au mois de mars 1 au mois de
mars dernier et ont il a eu des romains
des résultats tout à fait remarquable
alors qu'en france on disait que masque
était inutile et si les asiatiques les
japonais et taïwanais porte un masque il
ya bien une raison
et on voit les résultats aujourd'hui une
manière plus efficace que doux contre
cette pandémie en fini pas avant de
mettre tournés vers vous à nouveau je
vous propose
de voir la vie hier soir d'olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé qui
donnait une interview à nos confrères de
tf1 aujourd'hui dans notre pays
il a trop de cas quotidiens plus de dix
mille cas nous ne sommes pas en flambée
épidémique comme certains de nos voisins
qui ont dur qu'on finit en catastrophe
en france nous avons déjà pris ces
mesures de confinement plus tôt avec un
confinement qui a été important dans
notre pays au mois d'octobre et novembre
nous permettant d'éviter ce confinement
en catastrophe un florian philippot à la
ministre de la santé qui a exclu pour le
moment 1 re confinement vous êtes
d'accord le gouvernement ne peut pas se
permettre de re confiné car ils
pourraient s'exposer à une fronde
populaire en pleines fêtes de fin
d'année comme le disait eric straumann
peut-être 1re confinement du coup au
début janvier mais très probablement
qu'ils le feront
bien sûr comme il nous annonçait qu'il
ne serait pas deuxième confinement et
qu'ils l'ont fait et comme il nous a
annoncé hier qu'il allait repousser le
passeport salutaire vous savez qu'il
créera un citoyen du 8e jaune si vous
refusez le vaccin n'auraient plus droit
à rien ni de sortir mais ils le feront
si s'il trouve un prétexte un moyen de
le faire
vous savez nouveau bondi juste deux
secondes mais sur l'action là dixit est
il ya un grand pas qui est dans le vrai
le monde sur taïwan
c'est pareil dans tous ces pays là ils
ont surtout misé sur les antiviraux
alors qu'en france on a dit aux gens
vous restez chez vous vous prenez un
doliprane et quand vous suffoquer vous
appelez au total pour venir
éventuellement ivory ça c'est un pays
moderne traite les gens qui les soignent
nous ce qu'on refuse de faire pour de
sombres raisons très liée à des conflits
d'intérêts voire de la correction sur
les lits de réanimation ils sont
absolument pas saturé en france
aujourd'hui
donc je veux dire je suis quand même est
rare et de voir qu'on peut jouer on se
permet de jouer comme ça que la liberté
des gens et évidemment on le fait parce
qu'il n'ya pas de contre-pouvoirs les
partis d'opposition sont à plat ventre
les médias sont à propagande et le juge
administratif
à commencer par le conseil d'état sont
complètement à plat ventre aussi devant
l'exécutif
layrac nombreux pouvoirs donc on fait
n'importe quoi on joue comme ça avec les
commerces des restaurants les on va
avoir à thiers desailly ont joué avec la
liberté des gens et libertés
individuelles ça c'est complètement
délirant alors que l'on devrait investir
dans notre hôpital petit chypre aussi
sur la corée du sud il ya deux fois plus
de lits de réanimation par harris hank
en france 1 mais nous on en a fermé 110
milles
en 25 ans à la demande de l'union
européenne on devrait investir sur les
traitements arrêter de diaboliser
l'ivermectine le l'hiver les types de
l'hydroxyde de rock in vitro décide
alors avec diaboliser la prévention etc
je pense que c'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire c'est en train de tuer deux
pays
tout simplement moi je veux bien vous
conseille pour te qu'on s'agite comme ça
baltik un taux de mortalité de 0,05 pour
cent de femmes battues et la france donc
au bout d'un moment il faut arrêter
quand même le délire général
juste un petit mot aussi sur les masques
en sus il n'y a pas de masque il ya pas
eu de confinement ya rien et ils ont un
taux de mortalité aujourd'hui inférieur
à la france le 13 % même si la suède
après quand même des mesures de
restriction un petit peu plus car il y
aura de fermeture pas de confinement pas
les risques de dépendances
c'est une moyenne en suède hausse avec
la suède est un grand pays rural où il
ya en plus d'enseigner dans beaucoup de
circulation est dense à stockholm on est
à des taux qui était relativement un
faux lent et je crois que le masque a
été le secret d'hergé une erreur
toujours sur l'autographe de mon nom
mais l'homme ne le masque a été une
erreur qu'à traîner le gouvernement dès
le départ qu'ils considéraient que
c'était pas d'outils essentiels et je
crois que c'est un outil de lutte et de
prévention certainement le plus efficace
aujourd'hui pour revenir juste ce qui
était scandaleux et je suis d'accord
c'est que les soignants n'avait pas de
masque on était un pays où il avait des
sacs poubelles etc
on sait qu'il faut un masque dans les
blocs opératoires quand on accueille des
malades pour les médecins et les
soignants
par contre le maçon population générale
en particulier à l'extérieur va
énormément de médecins qui avoue cette
secte pour revenir sur ta voix tu es
circulent quand même avec des masques
des japonais aussi mais c'est passé
c'est pas de dire de pollution aux
convictions mais c est beaucoup d par le
thème de dima du débat sert confirmer
reconfirmer ou non par confiner vous
semblez être tous les deux d'accord en
tous les cas sur le fait que début
janvier il puisse y avoir un recond
finement annoncé peut-être par le tour
d'effectif
s'ils le font ce selon vous quid des
restaurants quid de la du monde de la
culture coûte de l'économie de la france
souhaitait que je réponde aux alizés un
petit mot pour vous et puis après oui je
le jure de rien je pensais que avec le
déconfite mandat il fallait des confiné
et toutes les activités en fixant des
règles au japon à taiwan les gens
peuvent continuer à aller à manger au
restaurant
j'ai regardé un peu comment ça
fonctionnait aussi deux côtés de la
frontière en allemagne on aurait pu
rouvrir les restaurants en acceptant
d'aider table de quatre personnes
ça fonctionne déjà aujourd'hui dans les
restaurants d'entreprise de cette façon
et on n'a pas signalé de clusters dans
les restaurants d'entreprises donc je
pense qu'on aurait pu réouvrir les
restaurants durant cette période de
déconfinement et perrier pas de preuve
scientifique on attrape plus le colis
dans un restaurant qu'ailleurs mais il
faut insister sur un certain nombre de
mesures de prévention et notamment par
le le masque des règles distanciation
sociale et on peut également traversé la
crise sans nécessairement re confiné
tout le monde moi j'en suis persuadé
qu'on finit actuellement concernés etc
auraient mené et je pense que il faut
éduquer enfin en tout cas expliquer à la
population la réalité de la situation et
prendre exemple à ce qui se passe
ailleurs là où ça fonctionne mieux mais
mot de la fin pour vous florian
philippot par rapport à cette histoire
de re confinement peut-être début
janvier par rapport à l'économie les
restaurants la culture bassoul et les
restaurants la culture l'événementiel
les bars et discothèques les forains
tout ce qu'il ya derrière les télés
traiteur à tous les métiers il y en a
énormément ce il va falloir que moi je
leur conseille de bouger de se muer en
2021 très sérieusement parce que là mon
avis ça va pas rouvrir le 20 janvier
c'est pas prêt d'ouvrir personne de
l'ordre qui leur a été pris à commencer
par leur boulot et leur capacité de
vivre avec leur boulot un peu beaucoup
je pense qu'il va falloir ce que vous
appelez donc à la mobilisation merci à
vous deux
straumann vers les républicains d'être
simard en alsace et florian philippot
président des patriotes